gotta take  foreign  there's no problem thank you very much  thank you very much hello  today  ukraine is an epicenter of unbearable  heart age and pain  i witnessed that very vividly today  around kiev  the senseless loss of life  the massive destruction  the unacceptable violations of human  rights and the laws of war  it is vital that the international  criminal court  and other u.n mechanisms conduct their  work  so that there can be  real accountability  the position of the united nations is  clear  as i said in moscow  russia's invasion of ukraine is a  violation of its territorial integrity  and of the charter of the united nations